hey guys so i came to the apple store
here i was really excited because i
wanted to test out the new imovie 09 but
it looks like they don't have it updated
yet so i'm sad that's okay i decided to
try to shoot this in 16x9 because
i don't know if you guys use imovie 08
or ip06 which is what i usually use
because i can't stand no wait but the
good thing about a weight is that you
can shoot from the eyesight and still
stretch it out to be 16x9 anyway um yep
i'm here at the apple store in
oh i wonder where hmm
if you want to take a guess you can take
a guess i've been here before so it's
not a surprise um i actually was going
to release a new video today
but
that didn't happen because the file size
ended up being over a gig
and youtube doesn't like that so i'm
gonna have to ditch the hd idea for that
one and just upload regular
um yeah that's all i will probably have
that up maybe tonight or tomorrow
morning depending i don't know
so that's all uh i'll see you guys later
oh
and take a quick little pull here if you
were to have
an ipod shuffle which color would you
get
tell me right now i need to know hurry
up
okay that's it
bye
oh one last thing
i actually really do enjoy seeing videos
that you guys make when you're at the
apple store so if you ever make any feel
free to leave them as a response video
to any apple store video that i've ever
made ever probably the newest one
because then more people will probably
see it okay that's it for real okay bye